well hello there citizens of the reject
Nation we're here and it is time for
another solo movie reaction to Nicholas
Cage and John Travolta in the 1997
Sci-Fi Action epic face off that's right
peeps somehow I have made it decades
through this life well into 2023 now
without ever having seen face off I
could not be more excited I feel like
it's rare these days that you get to go
into a movie with this particular blend
of anticipation but also just pure
bewildered curiosity I have heard so
much about this movie over the years and
yet somehow I feel like I have
absolutely no idea what to expect even
still which is just a feeling I'm going
to save her as we proceed here uh but
needless to say I'm a huge Nick Cage fan
from Moonstruck to Mandy Raising Arizona
too many films to name he has turned in
some of my favorite performances over
the years Big Love for John Travolta as
well these two are prolific and I cannot
wait to see what kind of weird Sparks
Fly as they Collide here in this film
but hey guys before we hop in why don't
you leave a like on the video that would
be very much appreciated subscribe and
hit that notification Bell and if you
want to get the full Fresh Off
experience come on over to patreon.com
the railragex sync up with your own copy
and see everything that doesn't make
these reaction highlights thank you to
prepper for editing these down and
without further Ado guys
It's Time To Face Off
[Music]
that's right
oh man okay so this will be like Peak
crossover woo oh I'm getting excited
you don't get a lot of Firsts like this
you know
it's like an alternate universe version
of The Punisher about to happen right
now Thomas Jane one
[Music]
[Laughter]
God already it's wasting no time
[Music]
it's all the eyes
that mustache too where is this in
relation to Raising Arizona
they're just having the best day oh yeah
oh
[Music]
no
Innocence Lost
[Music]
oh no
oh my
[Music]
God
oh god oh no oh poor guy punch me up man
you got it
[Music]
[Laughter]
Caster Troy okay finally put a a face to
the name to the face off I've heard yeah
cause I've heard the name Caster Troy
but I never realized that was that was
this
Sinclair is hot
[Laughter]
this is a fascinating amalgamation of
tones and and feelings and all sorts of
things
even here the first
three minutes
oh what
it's reminding me of like a James Bond
meets Da Vinci Code thing with him but
now it's
[Music]
oh
Jesus
the meme
[Laughter]
where are we in relation to when Rush
Hour was there
Convention Center that jet was just
charted Anderson Airfield guess who paid
the bill in cash Pollock's Troy put one
of our people on that plane Pollux
Castor and Pollux the cast like the
constellation shouts out to all my
Geminis and my Greek and Roman mythology
majors
[Music]
[Laughter]
all the crane shots and slo-mos and
walking and flapping and everything
[Music]
is that all drugs and then Chiclets
that's good buddy and love you so damn
much I'd have to kill you bro I hate it
when you call me bro
don't see Avatar the way of water you
guys are paid to protect them from
everybody including himself and stay
away from downtown on the 18th it's
going to be a little um
smoggy
oh jeez it's good brotherly love would
you like anything else once we're
airborne
a peach you know I can uh
if I were too late
my tongue would you be grateful
oh no
I'm very disoriented but this is quite
fun I'm having a very good time
[Music]
look at that heat as they bring the heat
Archer
Archer damn the things you do for the
batch
a little over under cranking on that
shot
nice uh cool
Dutch angle shot to pull into
no matter how dramatic it's still
freaking awesome
[Music]
all right let's do this
combo helicopter plane Chase I'm here
for it
boss oh damn
oh no oh my God
[Music]
oh damn oh no
oh yeah
hear them Rockets whistle
hell of a plane crash
class classic the man with the golden
guns
uh something tells me low bro's not
gonna make it out of this yeah
oh the ear Jesus
[Music]
oh damn
oh
nice wire gag
[Music]
that was some ADR that was pretty sweet
God both these dudes just double fisting
[Music]
sorry let's do this
who's getting sucked into the blades I'm
about to unleash the biblical plague
helle deserves hello
say how is your daughter anyway
your darling Janie your little Peach oh
boy oh no don't use anyone's family
members and Peach in the same sentence
ever again
I better pull the trigger
[Laughter]
baby sure
I don't know what we as a timeline does
did to deserve Nicolas Cage but I'm
happy it happened oh boy here goes oh
here it goes oh Jesus
okay I thought he was gonna get like
cheese gratered right through that thing
that's about to be like a like Resident
Evil the movie
you're all going to die down here it's
like yeah that's done left the building
nice Graceland reference or Leaving Las
Vegas you know which was the Nicholas
Cage Elvis movie you know Nicholas Cage
Elvis yeah you get the point
he changed the way you look every week
who are you supposed to be now
supposed to be me
not like you have a clue who I am
no it's good
be yourself I got him Eve
it's over it's over is it put in for a
desk job well I'll do counseling sit
down talk about Mike I'll do it anything
you want oh I just want you yeah
this is such a lovely scene I know I
know this isn't Gonna Last but that was
I'm glad they they took a minute for
that
oh god oh hey you knew it was coming
Pete
it had worse than Gulf War syndrome
I'm interested
green screen this
there is one other possibility
oh my I was gonna say I almost forgot
the the main premise of this movie
pulled in by all this other
ridiculous chaos
oh God you're keeping him alive okay
what if you could walk into air one
prison
and give Pollocks a nice big brotherly
hug
as Castor Troy Dr Walsh can alter the
likeness even the voice of a government
Witness
what we're suggesting for you Archer
isn't a permanent transplant like that
just a temporary Trade
temporary Trade is that based on any
kind of real technology it looked sort
of semi-plausible then we simply connect
the muscles tear ducts and nerve endings
so you want to take his face in mind
borrow
the procedures completely reversible
sure you have lived and breathed Castor
Troy for years get his game to talk
that's what I do what if you can't the
bomb will blow and Caster Troy will win
oh you said it you said it CCH Pounder
what was the last time you saw Caster
Troy hey
[__] you're right but know this
you're convicted felon on probation for
harboring Castor Troy one phone call
from me and your son will end up in a
foster home oh boy but you ain't got
nothing on me and you know it or I can
talk to your sister again
she's right outside
hey Sean oop
how's your dead son
[Music]
oh geez
oh yeah
okay okay I heard something about the
18th but that's all I know
good trick with the empty chamber Jesus
this is a black bag operation you can't
tell Lazaro and you can't tell your wife
excellent after that beautiful
cathartic scene
I'll do it of course yes
let's go let's get one more
quick Swig of
warm family life before we go back to
chaos things are gonna get better now
that you're home scar won't move but it
will heal if you will plus you got all
that chest carpet to
You Know cover it up
the righteous chest of hair
this thing won't fully end
until I did one last thing
oh
I feel so bad for her you're going back
on assignment again this last time
oh don't do the face thing now
I have a scar that if you can put this
back after it's like a reminder sure
I mean I guess they can do anything
it's a Skin lab
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice
[Music]
way to
do the gore gag without completely
showing it to you as well
[Music]
got like like 20 odd minutes ago this
wasn't even like a super sci-fi movie
and now and now
it's weird like this yeah it doesn't
feel like completely undergrounded and
yet it is like incredibly over the top
oh yeah
get that get that re-gloving on
are you okay
[Music]
yeah I still sound like me oh yeah we
gotta get you all Mission Impossible up
I've been planted a microchip on your
larynx it's fantastic but you'll have to
be careful pressure sharp blow even a
violent sneeze could dislodge it well
[Music]
I could eat at a peach for hours whoa
it's got two days to get Pollock to talk
either way Miller comes in moves you out
make the most of it
[Music]
cruelly
a glorious and terrible burden
it must become the man he hates
it's like a unique form of torture
oh
now you're in the prison from Andor
prison's one big magnetic field the
boots tell us where you are
how does any machine work in this prison
hey what's up
what's up Thomas Dune
oh boy you want to see what wasted looks
like little man
whoa
[Applause]
just getting right down to business jeez
I guess he must I don't know he must
have as many enemies in here as he does
in law enforcement
[__] you
come on
God the face that launched a thousand
memes
look how many more memes and like GIF
Loops is this movie gonna produce
oh
[Applause]
you gotta really want to kick a guy in
the nuts to override like a magnet boot
like that
whoa
[Music]
yes
it's gonna be like Hollow Man interlude
laughs
foreign
[Music]
cop it's cool
we're gonna deal with it
oh
Great Frame again
wow
what do you want
pick one God guess
yep
the outset it seemed like such a
reasonable question and then the truth
is staring in the face
the answer I should say
aren't they giving you your medication
in here what was my medication oh
I was gonna say the one part of the
Montage we didn't see was like all the
homework Alex I hand fed you those pills
for years
5x I haven't forgotten that
senses my reflexes my memory into the
day it's like a tab of bad quantracts I
don't even know why that's Yeti jumped
me yesterday
you had a sandwich with his wife and his
sister the night he was sent here
that bomb you build does deserve an
audience belongs in the Louvre
I guess the LA Convention Center will
have to do
hey okay he's in he did just the the
right amount of homework
it's very interesting yeah because it's
like this guy's obsessed over this dude
for years he certainly knows like a ton
about him but I'm like how many of the
finer yeah like only a brother would
know this details
does he have
you got a visitor
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
now that is between us nothing like
having your face cut off to disturb your
sleep read the newspaper lately
oh oh no
no
oh Tito
wow I torched all the evidence that
proves you're you okay so wow looks like
you're gonna be in here for the next
hundred years of course the evidence of
half the force jeez
a government job to abuse
oh God I missed that face
[Applause]
yep
wow
oh God what a predicament
but teasing you stop and I really hurt
hungry for you whoa Peach my peach
oh Jesus no no
you're not respecting my boundaries
I'm coming in Jane Janie you something
that I crave
what it is
no uh
when did you start smoking
you'll be seeing a lot of changes around
here
It's Got a Brand New Bag oh
ow
that's right be a friend rather than a
parent that's what you really want to do
I also wonder if they had to have
somebody who actually knows how to play
smoke rings for that reverse shot
the big [__] cop Archer cut them a deal
for turning States evidence your breath
has been released
[Laughter]
there's a bomb at the LA Convention
Center I'm Sean Archer and now
oh boy
what a nightmare just to be trapped as
this guy now seeing that face on you
makes me afraid my tiramisu might come
back up this nose his hair this
ridiculous chin
hahaha
leave the chin that is America's chin
first
before defusing the bomb what's that
Worth next question
oh my
so he's just planning to live as Sean
Archer for the rest of us
living days
protected by a tamper switch and it'll
take us hours to bypass
evacuate your team captain no but sir we
can't we can't disarm leave let me take
care of this now where's Chris Tucker
and Jackie Chan to break this up
huge
freaking who decides their user
interfaces
I get well Pollux I guess he he designs
it from the ground up I wouldn't mind
giving him a message
interception now our side's got the ball
sorry
jeez
you're gonna take that it's time for a
prison break I want to thank you
for uh
enduring all these years that I was an
insufferable boar did you just have a
surgical procedure
what
was the stick successfully removed from
your ass
[Laughter]
are you losing weight did you get a
haircut
nope it's just Viagra also shouts out to
Margaret Cho taking us back to the 90s
what
no
I'm supposed to forget all the promises
because you're going back into The Fray
oh
hell of a country
because the only place I'm going
is upstairs with you
you know
as incredibly messed up and creepy as
this is
uh I got no end to that thought
stressed that's not creepiest
how can I get these boots off they only
take them off in the clinic
right before they fry your skull
oh yeah he can withstand that he's got
the righteous indignation on his side
I'm out of cigarettes get back in line
Troy
I said I'm out of cigarettes whoa yeah
[Applause]
gonna go out smoking
see now you're slipping into the roll my
guy
whoa
oh wow
can I have a light
you know those things will kill you
get his boots
what's your mom doing here
I didn't touch your wife
oh good
but I know your wife loves you
so let's get out of here
a little more brain dead than duboff
oh
yeah not bad okay
Mama it's a jailbreak
good
nice
oh no
oh
damn
this is a really hardcore stunts in this
movie
I mean not not that I would expect
anything less from a John Woo flick but
this is it's just like so many movies
crashed into each other
[Music]
yes yes
open the doors and Rain Anarchy
oh no
[Music]
oh this poor guy give me your head
come on
oh God oh God
oh no
[Music]
oh
climb climb
what is his sand doors
he is in the prison for Andor all this
time I can't swim
before they get that video game combo
[Music]
what an epic fall
and then there's fly off no I guess he's
dead
oh my oh interesting
did they make sure to give him the the
scar
I feel like she would notice something
like that
Happy Birthday Mikey
oh he took our baby Sean he took our
little boy
oh caught a bit of the conscience
he's alive caster
is already
everybody feels about the 500 percent
uptick in face touching at the office
this week
man go to your mother's don't tell them
where you're going just go
whoever you are don't call again
yeah
I'm down you know it's true
it's true here who's calling
well if you're Sean Archer
I guess I'm Caster Troy
yes
nice
epic drum fills this is like the perfect
high concept
it's like it's such a simple cat and
mouse but with like the perfect sci-fi
twist
it's like the stakes are just
baked right in so you're still selling
Hobson and drugs to Cheryl and Phil Roy
manuscript
Caster Troy wearing Sean Archer's face
probably doesn't care that much but like
they're good at giving Archer Troy these
little ticks of yeah just like ways in
which he's not of this world little
suspicions I'm gonna get Sean Archer
he's vulnerable at home his house is
probably alarmed up the Wazoo code is 10
1986 that's his dead son's birthday
I want to just break your heart whoa
oh my God how is it that you know so
much about showing auction
hi uh sleep with his wife
oh my God
[Laughter]
it's happening right now
I'd like to take his his face
oh
cool
his face oh
the eyes
again it's coming off
[Music]
this is like every actor's dream this
movie like oh my God just the amount of
things
to do and play and oh
yeah there you go you're developing face
swap dementia
[Music]
calm down
calm down catch you later
yeah like Mr [__] invisible gives a
[__] about you anyway
calm down whoa yeah
whoa
well that aged kind of weird just giving
the casting
dress up like Halloween and ghouls will
try to get in your pants
yeah good point wear whatever you want
not that even this is that like
revealing anyway
full jacket pants
do you have protection
what do you mean like
hahaha
excellent transition
next time
let Carl take his pants down
slip this in his thigh twist it
[Music]
I guess it's dice to know Caster Troy
draws the line somewhere I am the king
I am the king of domestic life
expect me after all this time just to
just to jump on you
is that what you expect
Jesus
no
I figured he might drop it on some of
our own friends bro and if my eyes don't
deceive I think this fellow's beginning
to enjoy being you props to the guy who
plays Pollocks too I mean Travolta Nick
Cage obviously get the Limelight but
uh oh oh no
oh no
little boy
[Music]
of course
he's yours too oh no
oh no oh weird conflict
but of course
oh boy oh no
oh my God
Michael no it's Michael no no no no no
no no
what's the matter with you
oh
damn
whoa oh no
oh geez
that's a good idea baby listen to your
music
oh
we'll be over the rainbow with no time
wow
God always casings flying come on FBI
step it up for swatter whoever this is
in conjunction with
[Music]
yes
[Laughter]
pretty much
Swiss cheese the entire joint
[Music]
wow nice
boy
it's funny that I keep calling him Kaz
because we're at a point in Supernatural
where Kaz DL has body swapped somebody
not entirely dissimilar
why why
wow no
but oh
yeah start knocking dudes out
oh nice
[Music]
a golden IPO V shot you know who it is
no I hate the brain get out of here sure
are you all right go oh
oh wow
let's do it hey man
[Music]
yeah yeah what's your arterial spray
let's go
stand off let's do this
stand off you can't get back what you've
taken from me let's just kill each other
yep oh perfect yes
can you
oh yes you can
remember who you're really shooting
that's great
so silly but so Cinema I love it
that's my Venn diagram or cine meets
silly yes
[Music]
God charred ass right there
climb boys yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
brother
sir why are you so upset
it's just Pollux Troy
wowie no
that guy
last night's bloodbath I'm terminating
your war on Terrace whoa
what
I have something I want to confess yeah
what you do to him I am Caster Troy
ah yes you are
it's weird it's it's badass but it's not
but it is but
fish
[Music]
last time I saw you
was in this room
we had a fight when I said I had to go
away again oh no
oh
woman
I'm so bad for her
oh my God
it's a special ops surgeon
gave me uh casters
oh yeah and then somehow Castor came out
of his uh his coma and it killed
everybody who knew about the mission
sure
but not before transforming into me
oh my God no amount of therapy will ever
fix any of this
oh
oh beautiful Focus rack
oh yes I should love like the the
hypersaturated emotionality your husband
me my Sean's blood type is O Negative
oh
that's right I also have more salt and
pepper in my chest hair
it was our own diet today he had a heart
seizure
whoa
come to me
I very much enjoy his his Nick Cage
his Caster Troy yes
seek the research woof
Wowie
ah that must have been a very tiny
little needle to not uh you know produce
that big of a sensation
[Music]
[Laughter]
careful
yeah
[Laughter]
thank you for trusting me maybe Sean's
already dead huh
ah
yeah
I once
took a date out for surf and turf not
knowing she was a vegetarian
oh and uh and broke her tooth on her
right seat
oh we drove around all night
uh looking for a for a all-night dentist
he was so drunk
I fixed the wrong twos what when I
finally brought her home
I even
though it must have hurt like hell
yeah you you kissed me oh
go to him I I can never make it up to
you
oh you're damn well gonna try yes you'll
find the bastard
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh where is he hiding
what has got to think when he said his
wife runs off in the middle of the night
then I'm a doctor that's on call so
please let me get back to work okay
sorry
supplies distrust mixed messages
this is turning into a real marriage
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'll give it to you kind of a bar
sardonic bar first Jamie that's what I'd
like to know she stole fifty dollars
from my purse and took off oh he killed
my brother I'm not gonna let him take
you too I promise
Sean Archer is off your back for good
interesting nice we are here to
celebrate the life of Victor Lazaro
and nominee Patrice
the girls
release the girls there's got to be some
white doves like just around the corner
somewhere
there they are yep
we are officially
Peak woo
oh oh oh no
it's a message think about what you did
let's go
oh no
[Music]
no chill honey
honey oh of course there's no way that
wasn't gonna happen this is between us
leave them out of it yeah I'll do a
repeat of that one guy your son was an
accident
I wanted to kill you but you took it so
personally
why did you just kill yourself or Let It
Go
my father could no brother could either
neither could his sister oh Sasha what
the [__] are you doing here G Arch I
guess I'm crashing I'm Caster that's
Archer
I'm bored oh boy
what a predicament
how many this is like a six-way standoff
right now
yes
it's on the eyes
duck yep nice
[Music]
not in the Lord's House
what
damn
it's a very compact shootout
oh
damn that flip
[Music]
oh God
it's a cover
oh no Wanda this is Steve Archer
wowie
[Music]
oh boy
oh boy please God died
shut up honey don't listen to him honey
he's not your father hear my voice I'm
your father
whoa now we're gonna find out what's in
Papa's bag
peaches
oh Jesus
say goodbye to Papa oh yes
I should I should have thought that
would come back what a mess
[Laughter]
oh my dude
sound effects too
cheaper's is quite an explosion I get
every second of that
whoa
nice
[Laughter]
it's been a while since I've seen some
spirited boat stunts
[Music]
God this is like that game of chicken at
the beginning except on the water now
instead of on our tarmac and with way
more bloodshed
hahaha
[Laughter]
yup get all that coverage
that's awesome
but there's a lot of those after this
a lot of would-be Caster Troy swooping
those up
[Music]
whoa whoa damn dude the amount of drag
impressive whoa
careful with that
drop it whoa you're gonna clothesline
the both of you
wow
that looks so painful oh this poor stunt
guy oh my God
oh
yep just
silly but awesome
wow
to other stunt performers
[Music]
oh
Jeepers I'm exhausted
oh geez wow oh yeah it looks painful oh
you know oh
every time you look in the mirror
you can see my face sure
no
oh no no no no
oh geez
jigsaw why
wow end it with one more gift boy
you okay Archer
whoa what did you call me
Paulie Archer sir huh
hanging in their tops
receipt you're gonna be okay
oh boy
how much does the top surgical team from
DC know about all this theoretical
sci-fi face swappery walk is not that
theoretical but
yeah what matters
I won't need it anymore oh oh good
because we don't have that information
anymore
[Music]
come through the door looking like
Michael
angel from the movie Michael not the
dead child of theirs I mean no
disrespect
there's America's chin
oh all you two it's finally over
[Music]
a regular girl again
I'm here I'm sorry I shot you
[Music]
[__] face thing and so we have to ask
both of you
oh damn
he needs a place to live
hi
oh
come on
okay
these two
okay ah
Joan Allen that's her name okay
nice nicely done
whoo
wow that was quite
an experience
[Laughter]
oh my God I am I I I I I need to put my
brain back together
I need a moment to just
Center myself
[Music]
that was truly a slice of slice of the
90s man of the highest order like good
God what a wild experience
I do not make them quite like that any
longer I I must say
oh boy oh it's beautiful
okay you have to get the get the heads
head Twirl in there
God that whole bit with him is the
priest that was a Han Zimmer score fun
when it's not busy being like every you
know piece of classical music you've
ever heard or church music
Inferno artist there's a there's a
credit there's a title for you air
technicians certainly for this movie
printed on film
back when most all films were boy howdy
people
we have quite a bit to talk about let's
jump into this let's chat
[Music]
I'm still uh forgive me I'm still sort
of reeling from everything we just
witnessed um but that that was a blast
you know this is a famously crazy movie
and I feel like every time I come into
one of these especially you know a movie
like this you know with like a Disney
movie or something like that there's
like a different sort of expectation and
a different kind of pressure in terms of
what kind of enjoyment you're gonna get
out of it especially with any movie that
has you know particularly ingrained just
fan base or or reputation of any kind
um but this was yeah so much fun and and
so wild I mean this is the the kind of
movie I guess I I'm choosing to refer to
now as as fever cheese because uh it
does have this sort of madcap quality it
does feels sort of feverish in its just
hyper saturation of tone and emotion and
just the way in which everything is
cranked up to like 15 like it's very
operatic and certainly John Wu brings
that sort of over-cranked quality where
yeah everything is just as Vivid as it
could possibly be and uh and yeah for
the high concept at the core of it and
the the people I mean not only the two
star like of course the two stars John
Travolta Nicholas Cage uh bouncing off
each other but just the array as well of
notable that guys and character actors
and just interesting people popping up
like this is a very colorful and and
bombastic movie in a way that's like
almost over it's quite overwhelming
actually but in a way that that yeah has
this sort of unbridled spirit that uh
it's a cliche now but like they they
really don't seem to make them like this
very often anymore because this is just
so very much what it is it's like it's
like an unfiltered ID in a lot of ways
it's just you've got this classic setup
of you know this this murderous
sociopath Master criminal versus this
you know fixated uh just overly
dedicated and moralistic well not even
moralistic I mean he's just so obsessed
with catching this guy Sean uh Archer
that yeah he's willing to go to any
lengths he's neglecting his family his
life is sort of all revolving around
this and it's just about these two sort
of Polar Opposites you know cat and
mousing with each other and uh and yeah
I mean so much of it is just the you
know unique choices that they pour into
it and yes the high concept at the
center of it we're gonna have these two
guys switch cases so you have a you know
Performance swap essentially you get to
watch as both Nick Cage and John
Travolta set up who uh Castor Troy and
Sean Archer are and then yeah the fun I
would say begins with the fun just
begins immediately because Nick Cave
just chewing
all the scenery chewing through the
frame and like into the TV or whatever
kind of border is encapsulating the
movie itself like he is on a a wholly
different plane and it's fascinating to
me that this movie works in the way that
it does as well as it does like I don't
know this is again I'm fascinated to
hear and discuss this with people to
hear more opinions and to discuss this
with people because it is certainly over
the top and wild and cheesy and and and
sci-fi High Concept in a way we're sure
you know if you start to poke too hard
at any one piece of logic or way they
explain away certain aspects of the
general conceit I mean sure you're going
to come up with holes and all sorts of
other you know problems perhaps
um but yeah I don't know there's just
something about this that is everything
that it needs to be like it fully
understands the assignment and yeah I
think it's a really fun exercise to
watch as the these two actors trade
because I mean they've got two very
different acting Styles and two
different uh performances to emulate and
I think it's interesting to watch I mean
props to John Travolta like Nicholas
Cage and I think rightfully so is sort
of in his own universe and orbit for
this entire experience like he is even
as Sean archer in a way he is still kind
of in his own
pocket within the rest of the you know
electron cloud of the movie the rest of
the you know sort of faculties that make
this experience what it is if you remove
any of the different pieces I think a
lot of it would fall apart like this is
I think one of those moments where the
right combination of people collided to
really sell this and it's it's fun and
interesting because yeah I mean this
Harkens back to a time I mean it's
certainly it's very much of the 90s but
it also reminds me some of the pulp of
the 80s as well it has almost like a
there's like a verhoveniness about it
you know there's some RoboCop in there
there's some of that sort of wacky sort
of Sly sardonic Edge coming from behind
the camera while you watch you know this
High concept chaos play out in the you
know beats of the story and all that but
yeah just the way that they balance each
other out and the way that you know
earnestly uh John Travolta sets up this
Sean Archer guy I mean you're watching
him in the beginning moments in the most
intimate you know throws of Joy just you
know enjoying a day on the carousel at
the park with his kid Nick Cage with
this freaking mustache
um and yeah you know like it's a classic
setup you know this assassination
attempt gone awry he loses his kid this
starts a chain reaction of obsession
that will swallow his life and strain
his marriage and estrange him from his
daughter and send her down you know a
risky path and all that and the only way
to stop it the only way to get any kind
of peace is to put this guy away then to
twist the knife to come up with this
scenario in which yeah this bomb is
planted and you know half the equation
half the puzzle half the info we need is
hidden and concealed because Castor Troy
goes into a coma Pollux Troy has the
rest of the information what do we do
you gotta go undercover as the guy you
hate the most in this world you have to
wear his face like it's a fascinating
again vehicle for fun and hijinks but
it's also like intrinsically
sort of
odd and uncanny and and messed up and
psychologically harsh and I do
appreciate the way that they played
those aspects and those elements because
yeah it's like at first you know John
Travolta is anchoring this with like the
seriousness he's Batman basically he's
being Bruce Wayne he's dedicated to the
mission and you know he's trying to
maintain some kind of personal life or
whatever but mostly he just wants to
take this guy down once and for all he
thinks he's maybe done it but up turns
out he's not dead and uh and hey you uh
you remember how I said you know things
were going to be different now because
uh you know the the chase is finally
done well they they pulled me back in
just when I thought I was out they
pulled me back in and uh and yeah
watching them as they trade characters
is very gratifying because
I don't know from there the game is set
I mean they both translate the heart
it's like while Nicholas Cage and John
Travolta each have very I would say
different acting Styles and that is
certainly the case it's on display here
um they do manage to like balance out
the heart of this because I mean John
Travolta approaches Sean Archer when
he's just Sean Archer you know with a
certain level of just sincerity and then
when he's at work you know when he's on
the job you know he's very no-nonsense
he's very focused on the mission and
then of course Nick Cage's Caster Troy
is just like again the unbridled ID he's
just completely debauched and anarchic
and gleeful and wild and he's just
grabbing everyone's ass and you know I
mean yeah he's he's just Hedonism
incarnate he is very much the Joker to
Sean Archer's Batman essentially than to
watch him as he sort of has to Grapple
with the psychological torment of the
mission on Archer as Troy while I would
say that John Travolta gives the more
like ground not to call anything in this
movie grounded but he gives the more
naturalistic performance I guess and I
thought he did a really nice job at body
and Caster Troy it's funny we're in a
period in Supernatural what uh watch
alongs and reaction highlights on
patreon where not exactly but there's a
body swap-esque scenario happening with
one of the characters and they're not
you know the stakes and the details
aren't the same but the effect of the
one character inhabiting the other and
then getting to watch that actor emulate
the other actor is uh is one that I've
very much I I can feel them drawing
inspiration from this because yeah you
have this guy in Caster Troy who is just
so mocking and jeering and such an imp
and so to watch Travolta then do that
you know 180 and to inhabit him is
really fun and gratifying and I think he
does a terrific job like his is imp
impressive for that I could feel the
amount of study and I think he's even
said that like yeah I mean you know my
job was a little easier and then I get
to emulate Nicholas Cage who has already
even Justice himself without all the
extra you know expressionist and Kabuki
inspired acting techniques he's already
you know a pretty recognizable character
um so yeah for Nick Cage emulating John
Travolta I thought it was interesting
it's a little bit more of an
impressionistic or or an expressionistic
approach in that it's not quite as
naturalistic as Travolta's doing him
but I I don't know like there's
something about Nick Cage where you're
like he does have to do this weirder job
almost because Castor Troy doesn't care
about coming across as John Archer he
you know holds it together just enough
he he pays enough attention to just
enough of the facts and things to get by
um but you know I guess everybody's kind
of noticing that he's behaving
differently and he's embracing this sort
of like this is a whole new me kind of
thing whereas Sean Archer as Castor Troy
has a much more difficult time slipping
into the character and I like that while
there were times where I was like don't
you know this guy like better than
anyone though and wouldn't before doing
like it seems like he just he had that
period of like I'm definitely not gonna
do this he goes home he thinks about it
a little bit and he's like well this is
the chance to put the final nail on the
coffin so I I guess I'll I'll do it uh
but you know I feel like we missed a
whole period of time where he would have
done some a little bit more studying
just dystopian character uh but you know
I grad they also don't have time for
that given the time bomb that is
literally going to go off in several
days
um so yeah you know watching him
infiltrate the prison and be sort of
reluctant to inhabit the role of Castor
Troy I think was a fun thing and
something that Nicholas Cage did handle
very strikingly like again even if his
acting style is more Broad and is
encompassing of less naturalistic
approaches I do think he did a really
fun and interesting job of showing the
anguish of Sean Archer though a bit
broadly perhaps uh still you know
selling it earnestly and then you know
really kind of relishing in a different
kind of wildness as he has to sort of
play the the weird like mental
dissonance and perhaps sort of breakdown
that needs to happen as Sean Archer
surrenders to this process to it habit
Caster Troy at least well enough to get
some information from his brother and
you know navigate through this prison
which again I guess Andor must have
taken some big inspiration from that
with the whole uh electromagnetic floors
and it being out at Sea and all that
stuff it's fun it's fun to see uh even
on this first watch just touch Stones
where I've seen this movie referenced in
other places because certainly it has
been quite influential over time but
yeah even those little nuances like the
way Pollux is clearly suspect of Caster
when he first arrives at the prison you
know he's very subdued he's not behaving
you know in the manner that Caster Troy
has behaved up until this point and who
better to pick up on something like that
being off than his own brother and a
character who has been well established
as being very close to him both
intellectually but also emotionally
certainly and and props to Alessandro
navola just for keeping up with and
playing off of especially Nicholas Cage
because you know you have John Travolta
Nick Cage at the center there the
spotlight performances but I think the
Supporting Cast goes a long way to
pinning down and grounding the rest of
the movie around them and yeah I thought
he really just naturally played as this
guy's you know brilliant but more
subdued younger brother and I loved the
way that his Gaze on Archer Troy you
know creates this tension as he tries to
infiltrate and get the information that
he needs because you never get the sense
that he is entirely convinced of what he
is seeing even though you know you don't
think he's gonna you know come to the
conclusion that some kind of sci-fi
procedure has taken place yeah they just
they just always kind of Leave You
uneasy that like his brother can tell
and I really like the way that they then
use the meme during that prison fight
you know where Caster looks up at Pollux
which by the way uh excellent choice of
names caster and Pollux the uh the
mythical twins Gemini I see you and I'm
here for it justice from a Gemini is out
there I know you get a bad rap uh but
yeah the way he's like looking up at him
and it clearly Dawns like oh I cannot be
wearing the anguish and the weight of
this ordeal in my face I can't be
looking like I'm on the verge of tears
and like flinching every time I come
across a guy who Sean Archer put in jail
here who I'm about to be spending some
very close quarters time with I gotta
give myself over to the assignment to
the character to the ruse and yeah then
watching as he sort of goes from this
realization to them like okay yeah I
gotta get nuts you know and and watching
as he then subsequently you know sort of
forms his own version of what being
Castor Troy is like I like that yeah
they don't just become each other
full on and and you even get the sense
of like did did he do enough research to
be able to sell this it seems like you
know once he recanted on his initial
turning down of the assignment uh he
kind of just launched right into it and
I know he knows a lot about this guy but
at the same time it seems like there was
some homework left on the table but
either way they both kind of assume each
other's lives and then in ways you can't
call it improving them but they you know
sort of fill in gaps where things were
missing or at least sort of bring into
heavy relief the things that were
missing and I mean you know in in Sean
Archer's life a lot of that comes across
in some very creepy intimate moments
with uh Eve especially Joan Allen's
character who I thought she I felt so
bad for her but I thought she did a
really nice job and she had a lot of
poison Grace as this you know innocent
caught up in this terrible sordid
Twisted web of circumstance
um and then Dominic Swain as well uh you
know very uncomfortable you know wholly
different way
when Troy Archer is like you know
getting uncomfortably close to her and
stuff like that while he's pretending to
be cool dad I guess
um but yeah having like the the sheer
unsettling quality of that and then him
going into the office and you know using
his own crime to elevate his version of
Sean Archer's profile to be like you
know top FBI agent freaking Time
Magazine person of the year and then
meanwhile you have Archer Troy who you
know is only doing like the things that
he absolutely has to in order to embody
this guy and then also kind of like
trying to be a better guy about it like
that whole thing with Gina Gershon who I
also really liked in this where she's
like coming onto him in the bedroom and
uh he's like clearly very uncomfortable
with that and he basically rebukes her
in that moment and you know you get the
sense that yeah like regular Caster Troy
he would probably be all about this
um but you know he seems to actually
kind of extends some kind of sympathy
towards her that she does pick up on and
that creates sort of an interesting
Turning Point wherein she starts to look
upon him in a different way and I mean
it's not actually Castor Troy growing as
a human being but for her it sort of is
which is just again another interesting
weird little Nuance that then yeah
blossoms outward into uh Archer as Troy
looking out for her and then ultimately
opening the door for him to adopt Young
Adam and bring everything full circle at
the end when you know Hollywood morality
dictates that uh that Mom has to die and
I mean you know she has a certain
tragedy to her character as well just
because yeah I mean she is clearly In
Too Deep with Caster Troy and his whole
organization and whatever her weird
relationship is with her brother like
yeah I think she has a really nice
presence and is a very nice Counterpoint
to Eve while also yeah opening the door
up for a very sort of poetic and very
kind of Hollywood romantic uh wrap up
for this core wound that exists within
the character of Sean Archer to the
point that he literally you know at the
end decides to erase that core woo he
doesn't need the core wound anymore the
wound is healed the wound he has been so
particular about throughout the whole
film which did they bother to put that
on Sean Archer Caster Troy when he got
the face put on what he have known that
like because I feel like Eve would have
definitely noticed something like that
but anyway you know the literal closing
of the core wound nice but yeah man just
like so many great uh little guest stars
and uh and and that guy actors and
things like that I mean you got Nick
cassavetes you got comb fiori John
Carroll Lynch CCH Pounder Robert wisdom
Matt Ross freaking Margaret Cho uh who
was like again another one of those
people who brings me right back to this
moment in time this had such a fun and
interesting array of just weird little
human quirks and things like that on top
of all just the opulent set design and
costuming and music and the action of
course I mean this is a John Wu film
John Woo excels certainly is certainly
renowned for his action and I'm sitting
here going why in God's green earth was
mission Impossible too so
not this I mean not that it should be
exactly this but that movie is sort of
famously and perhaps egregiously sort of
dull for all of the you know fun and
interesting things it has going for it
and yeah you look at something like this
and you're like this is like an anime
come to life in a lot of ways I mean it
has so many of those classic tropes as
well which those are also borrowing from
various you know movie and Hollywood and
other Traditions too but yeah you just
have this like extreme height of every
tone no matter what scene you're in like
it certainly is most obvious during the
action scenes where everyone's like dual
wielding and they're doves flying by and
seagulls in certain cases yeah you've
got like a helicopter chasing a plane on
the tarmac with a bunch of cars and then
they're all crashing into a hangar and
then you know at the end you've got a
speed boats chasing each other and
you've got you know them fighting them
as each other and then them fighting
them as themselves and all sorts of
different switcheroos and and I mean the
action certainly is stylish and it's fun
to see it all on film certainly more
obvious I think when you have stunt
doubles doing certain things but yeah
there's so many interesting little set
pieces that take place in all these
different unique locations and whatnot
uh and then you know the LA Convention
Center getting a lot of play for crime
movies in the mid 90s and going for that
sort of sweeping epic classical music
you know this sort of irony of Castor
Troy as again this sort of unbridled
monster but who has this sort of
hoity-toity taste just the same
um you know then the title it's just so
well chosen you know obviously first off
but they're facing off and then at the
end you've got them facing off literally
divided by a wall each looking into a
mirror talking to each other so that
they're looking upon the face they're
truly talking to even though they're
wearing it like it's such a like it's
one of those movies where like to
describe it makes you sound like you're
on drugs and I think that's a really fun
thing and yeah this is why one of those
movies that I think just gets by on the
blunt force of its convictions and of
its commitment again to every Tone It
attempts to inhabit like when it's being
an action movie it's being a hundred and
fifteen percent in action movie when
it's doing something intimate and
perhaps romantic or at least you know
sort of longing in a in a romantic kind
of way it is a 115 percent that sort of
romance novel level of Pulp and
commitment uh when it's about you know
crazy Globe trotting maniacal
sociopathic criminals it is 115 that
weird kind of thing and and it commits
you know with like the full range I
think that's that's why the cheese works
is because it is fully committed in such
a hammy kind of way like everybody kind
of seems no matter how subtle or not
they're playing it to realize that's the
movie they're in and the more I sit here
the more I think about it the more the
this does really feel like some kind of
anime where you know you have these two
archetypical characters these two
Paragons of two different philosophies
aimed at one another who were just not
going to stop until one or both of them
is dead and gone for good and yeah just
like the way the again emotionality is
infused into everything and the way
everything is just as Vivid and
saturated and heightened as it could
possibly be like yeah this is like I
would posit this as like one of the best
live-action animes that isn't an anime
just because the more I sit here the
more I take it all in I'm like yeah
that's exactly what we just saw like
like you throw a rotoscope over this and
these are like the character types the
weird you know situations that unfold
the weird violations of you know
people's personal space and his social
contracts in general and the you know
just chaotic array of details that
comprise each one of the these
characters in the world that they live
in and the slight sci-fi flourishes that
the movie has beyond all that because
it's not even that sci-fi but it is but
it's not you know like the central
conceit is but it's not really taking
place in a world that feels very far
beyond our own so yeah man like this is
just such a fascinating Moment In Time a
time capsule most certainly and one of
those I think special movies where just
the right people coalesced at the right
time and all got on the same page
together and committed to I mean
something that with a with a concept
where if you do half a good job
something entertaining should come of
this but yeah then you get all of these
talents and all these people who are
clearly inclined to embrace the
opportunity and the challenge of just
going completely all in and over the top
I mean yeah I can see why this has the
meme and cult and classic status that it
does and I had an absolute blast so guys
leave me your thoughts anything you want
to point out anything I might have
missed and uh yeah let me know what
other movies you might want to see
reactions to uh I haven't seen Con Air
that's another Nick Cage joint I could
check out there are probably a few Nick
Cage joints out there that I still need
to catch up with but uh but yeah I'm so
glad to have finally seen this and to
have been able to share this first watch
with you uh just
I could go on forever with the craziness
of this movie but I think that's that's
all the main stuff that ought to be said
So yeah thank you for joining me if
you've joined me leave a like on the
video subscribe and all that good stuff
and last but not least let's do a
patreon of the day shout out
Andrew Hayes listen Andrew if there's
anybody at the patreon whose face I'd
like to take off and swap out for my own
it's you Andrew you have been one of our
most loyal you know us better than most
people out there do or could possibly
hope to imagine and that's why I want to
assume you're alive I feel like you know
enough about me that you could slip in
undetected all we would need is to
change faces we're pretty close and
similar in body type and that way I
could walk a mile in your shoes maybe
improve your living a little bit you
know try my hand at your life as a as a
creative person in a locksmith and you
can come here here and make big
reactions you know what I mean so uh
Andrew
the further I go this this Nick Cage is
kind of falling apart
um but hey buddy thank you for being
here for all the love that you've shown
us over so much time you know we don't
get to catch up often but it's always
great when we do and I hope you're doing
well out there and uh yeah whose face do
you want to take off man let me know and
uh we'll catch you on the next one much
love cheers
foreign